oh doctor so many lives
so many adventures let's rank them
[Music]
so earlier this month i hit 50 000
subscribers
which was amazing that is a huge huge
milestone and it
means the absolute world to me and i
decided i need to do something
big something special as a result
of that but what i mean what's the
standard sort of thing
q a my live streams every two weeks
basically just a free-for-all q a how
would that be special
ah that didn't work some people
suggested you know reviewing something
that people have been asking for but the
thing is
most the thing that the bulk of people
have been asking for i have
at least in some way addressed if not
here than in the break room
or people have commissioned me to review
stuff that wasn't going to work either
said no we're gonna go
big we're gonna go
possibly stupid
possibly insane
we're gonna rank every single episode
of modern era doctor who not classic
still haven't seen all of it i'm i'm
working on it i'm working on it
maybe in time for a hundred thousand i
will have seen
all the classic and then i can do this
thing like for real truly everything
but for right now this is
every single episode of modern era
doctor who
ranked couple of things before i get
started one
these are going to be super brief
explanations for their placement
because i don't want this thing to be
five hours long
number two do not hold me
to this ranking this is the order that i
put them in
for this video i am not going to come
back and reference it
when i do future rankings of anything
more specific
so eventually when i rank capaldi's
episodes individually if
the episodes from his era are in a
different order than they are here tough
that's just what's going to happen this
is what happens when you have adhd
i don't care about being consistent my
opinions change my whims get indulged
it's going to be ever shifting but today
having hit 50 000 this is what the list
is going to be
i'm also going to go about it slightly
odd i'm not starting at the bottom
i'm not starting at the top i'm starting
in the middle
because if i start with the worst well
that's stuff i can get worked up about
go to the best that's stuff i can get
worked up about it's going to be a big
lull in the middle so we're going to
start at the low
i'm going to start with the two in the
middle which
come in at ranked number 84 and 83
and then we're going to alternate
worst to best so it'll be 84
83 85 82
86 81 it'll make sense as we go about it
i hope so maybe it won't screw it this
is what i decide what i'm gonna do
and i've gone on too long already let's
do it
number 84 the ghost monument number 83
deep breath thing is even though this is
dead middle this doesn't mean that these
are mediocre these are ones that for the
most part i actually like
ghost monument good fun adventure i
enjoy it deep breath
solid start not one of the best but it
worked number 85
planet of the ood i enjoyed donna
but there's a lot about this that feels
a little undercooked
number 82 husbands of river song i
love the back half of this the front end
is a little bit
too much farcical stuff number 86
rose people hammer at me for this one
but i'm sorry outside of the dynamics
specifically between the doctor and rose
i don't think there's much to this story
number 81 curblam
corker of a story really rollicking
adventure uh there's some iffy
ethical things going on there in terms
of where the doctor lands
87 listen boy do i wish i loved this one
more but the more i go back to it the
more i'm like there's so many cracks in
this thing but dang that opening
monologue
number 80 waters of mars some really
good tension some really good
performances but
i feel in a lot of ways it's kind of
overrated and i never really found it
scary
88 curse of the black spot probably rank
it higher than most people would i have
a soft spot for pirates i'm not saying
it's a great episode i just have fun
angels take manhattan falls apart
logistically good emotional core
89 revolution of the daleks good fun
vibe i enjoyed it but
there isn't a lot of substance number 78
flesh and stone this is where i can
point out that i am
not going to be joining together two
parters i'm gonna be ranking each part
separately
so flesh and stone felt like a little
bit of a letdown from the setup
part of the resolution i just think is
kind of cheap number 90 partners in
crime
boy do i love seeing donald with the
doctor again but i i don't care for the
story
number 77 army of ghosts very good setup
but not a lot to it outside of just
being able to set up the next
one number 91 the woman who fell to
earth it is a solid start
and that's kind of all i've got number
76 ascension of the cybermen some really
interesting ideas going on with the
cybermen here
it did kind of hinge on the next part
nailing it though number
92 the hungry earth decent silorian
story
pretty good tension in terms of the
build up to their reveal
number 75 hide i am a sucker for a nice
atmospheric ghost story type thing
this is that and i do enjoy it it's not
exceptionally deep but it's fun
number 93 cold blood slightly below the
first half
because it's got a weird opening with
the voiceover but still good stuff
number 74 the sound of drums i'm still a
little iffy on this sort of manic
version of the master but
this does a lot of interesting setup
number 94 the last of the time lords
it's a really cheap jack deus ex machina
ending on this thing and it's not great
number 73 pyramid at the end of the
world fascinating
setup really intriguing stuff makes you
want the next half
number 95 the next doctor pretty much
rides on the character of jackson lake i
enjoy him a lot but outside of that it's
fluff number 72 the end of time part two
back half of this is really drawn out
still some solid stuff and some strong
performances though
number 96 rosa it's not bad but my
feelings on this one
complicated it just doesn't quite pull
together for me number 71
poison sky some of the conflicts are
resolved a little anticlimactically but
it's a good rollicking way to round out
this two-parter number 97 the lodger
i kind of like the dynamic between craig
and the doctor but
it's just a lark of an episode number 70
last christmas the tact on way to keep
clara around notwithstanding a really
interesting mix
of holiday cheer and horror 98
the girl who died some decent banter the
rest of it is
twice upon a time feels really
unnecessary
in a lot of ways but it does still
really do a good job of finding
the heart of the story it's telling
number 99 voyage of the damned
bloated as heck still has some fun
moments though
the end of time part one i found the
tension in this to be aces
and the ending that was a brilliant
cliffhanger number 100
rise of the cybermen the entire first
half of this feels pointless given that
the fact that it's the cybermen is given
away in the title and then the rest of
it is just
fine 67 the witch is familiar
missy is great the interaction between
davos and the doctor is
just gold it gets undercut by stuff that
goes on later on but man that stuff's
still real good
101 the age of steel it's just kind of a
decent enough wrap up to what came
before
i really do love the music that is the
score for the cybermen though
the sontaran stratagem great
reintroduction to a classic
era villain this is some really fun
stuff
102 the beast below it really feels like
the wrong place in the series to be
doing this and it doesn't quite earn a
lot of what it's going for
number 65 the magician's apprentice that
cold open though
holy crap that is so good plus i love
the reintroduction of missy and the
doctor in this
love it all number 103 daleks in
manhattan
actually some interesting setup terrible
accents notwithstanding but it is also
one of those ones that was going to
wholly depend on the second part
number 64 turn left i think better of
this one now than i used to
because well a lot of it feels sadly
prescient but
still just not my favorite kind of story
number 104 boomtown i actually really
like the
interactions between the doctor and the
one remaining slovene
but that's about the only real highlight
of this
number 63 thin ice really good job at
firmly establishing the dynamic between
bill and the doctor
and a surprisingly strong story besides
number 105
tooth and claw there are some moments in
this that i absolutely adore but the
effects don't hold up worth a damn and
the story is kind of laughable
number 62 gridlock i admit i just have a
soft spot for this the pace the
adventure sense of it
and i just love the idea of taking a
traffic jam and making it this epic
number 106 the woman who lived
fascinating concept that is just not
done justice by this story at all
number 61 robot of sherwood it's the
banter
this is some of the best banter and i
have no shame in ranking it
this high just for that number 107 a
christmas carol it's the most christmasy
christmas episode that ever christmased
that's kind of all i've got number 60
time of the angels really good tension i
like
some of the new ideas introduced into
the idea of the angels number 108
dinosaurs on a spaceship i've actually
got a soft spot for a lot of what's
going on here but i
i can't really defend it number 59 smile
again really good establishing of bill
and the doctor and the way she is
different from other companions and
it's a pretty neat idea and i've come to
appreciate it more with
more viewings number 109 the bells of
saint john
the introduction of the most boring
version of clara and no real proper
justification for why the doctor gets
involved
before the flood really good wrap up the
look on the fisher king is really neat
some very cool
tiny whiminess but there's a couple of
oddities about this episode
that hold it back a bit 110 into the
dalek not
bad so much is just not much beyond just
what it is which is a mashup of several
previous story lines
number 57 flatline just a
solid tense adventure and the inversion
of the relationship between clara and
the other people there which normally
would have been the relationship between
the doctor and the other people
interesting
number 111 let's kill hitler it's fun
it's got a rollicking vibe but it's a
mess number 56
fugitive of the jedoon a lot of this
rides on joe martin but
man does she command the screen number
112 the shakespeare code
pretty good performance from the guy
playing shakespeare and some really good
music but other than that it's just
generic history set stuff number 55 the
fires of pompeii
this one gains more weight over time and
i actually really appreciate the way
this lays out how
donna makes the doctor better number 113
the zygon inversion look
that uh closing speech is amazing
but it overshadows absolutely everything
else a lot of what else is going on is
not very well thought out or executed
number 54 the parting of ways a real
good way to
sum up eccleston's time as the doctor
and give him a good final stand
number 114 unicorn and the wasp again
some fun banter nice setting don is fun
but that's kind of it it's just
bland number 53 the return of dr
mysterio i put this so high because i
like superheroes and i like what doctor
who did with them
number 115 nikola tesla's night of
terror
i didn't dislike it but you know what i
struggle to remember anything that went
on in it
number 52 the end of the world this
is a great way of bringing in all the
insanity that doctor who promises for
future episodes
number 116 the christmas invasion picks
up beautifully once
tennant comes out of his coma prior to
that
number 51 spy fall part two
largely carried by sasha dewan's master
but boy
does he really do a lot to carry this
some neat visuals too
number 117 cold war
ice warriors cold war era pun
that duran duran that's it number 50
under the lake so much great tension
from those ghosts
and the setup and the mystery around it
oh you drew me in
number 118 praxius
plastics are bad yeah i know
what else you got number 49 smith and
jones one of the best introductions for
a new
companion and really establishing right
off the bat why the doctor's drawn to
her
number 119 a town called mercy cyborg in
the old west
is there any more to that pitch no not
really number 48
girl in the fireplace some really
excellent moments i think it's overrated
in a lot of circles but
it is still real good number 120 bad
wolf
i'm sorry i hate the reality and game
show parodies i just hate them
number 47 the stolen earth really good
way to ramp up things to an
epic level for the end of series 4.
number 121
time heist i'm a sucker for a heist and
i
still didn't really connect too much
with this number 46 the haunting of
villa diadatti
i have some issues with some stuff that
goes on towards the end but
man the atmosphere on this and the
tension is gold
number 122 night terrors even as a
parent i still can't connect with this
thing number 45 the rebel flesh
setting up some interesting intrigue
questions of humanity and duplication
and where do we go from here
hmm number 123 the snowman
i find this version of clown more
interesting the real one so
there's that number 44 spyfall part
one fast-paced good fun cliffhanger mwah
number 124 the vampires of venice
really good music
really good music number 43 the pilot
terrific introduction to the status quo
of where the doctor's at an introduction
to bill
number 126 the unquiet dead really
setting the template for why i get bored
by most of the historical set episodes
for the modern era number 42 the
impossible astronaut
ooh the intrigue the doctor's dead what
are these things that nobody can
remember
you got me number 127 aliens of london
some
really great moments but they're pretty
small especially when compared to the
fighting aliens
number 41 death in heaven i think this
is a really strong
firm establishment of who missy is and
what her dynamic with the doctor is
and i think the mission statement of who
the doctor is at the very end
overrides all the problems for me number
128
the empress of mars ice warriors getting
the shaft again colonialism in space had
some potential but just
none of it's here number 40 school
reunion the return of sarah jane mr
finch is the villain
bring it on number 129 the power of
three actually
really interesting idea with the doctor
being stranded having to go the slow
lane just waiting for time to pass
but it all falls apart at the end like
really bad number 39 asylum of the
daleks
i think it's fun i just have fun
number one thirty world war three
[Music]
yeah that about does it number 38 dark
water intriguing disturbing and oh the
reveal of those cybermen
number 131 victory of the daleks a lot
of neat ideas none of which live up to
their potentials and ultimately none of
which meant anything later either even
though they were clearly meant to number
37
utopia i am the master
that's all that's all you need to know
number 132 resolution
neat idea for a specific kind of dalek a
bit op
though and the family stuff didn't work
number 36 the satan pit the doctor
versus the devil how's that going to
work
quite well as it turns out number 133
the lie of the land
just what what
what number 35 the god complex
turning a hotel into a labyrinth the
concept behind the way the minotaur
works oh
this is good stuff number 134 the big
bang
it's not a story it is an exercise in
tying up plot threads
and moffat going look how clever i am i
can tie all these together i don't care
tell me an interesting story
number 34 the name of the doctor now see
that is an
interesting story almost probably paid
off clara's whole nonsense too
number 135 the doctor the widow and the
wardrobe i do like
madge but like she's kind of all it's
got number 33
the almost people i actually love the
themings in this and the way that it
came down on this
particular conflict it's good number 136
the runaway bride donna may be my
favorite companion but
boy is she insufferable in this and the
story ain't good besides
number 32 demons of the punjab an aspect
of history that
i think is not taught as thoroughly as
it should be
and a really compelling story with a lot
of heart number 137 the crimson horror a
lot of potential in the pitch that just
none of it lives up what a waste of
diana rig number 31
day of the doctor i may be wishing that
they had done something more
closely focused on john hurt but this
still feels like a nice celebration
number 138 the caretaker jokes are lame
villains lame whole thing's lame
number 30 it takes you away this is the
kind of
weirdness i want from doctor who all the
time
number 139 planet of the dead planet of
the
absolutely boring alien design and dull
story
number 29 extremist really good
self-contained
as a bonus sets up later stories that
weren't as good but still
number 140 42 that
one parting of the doctor and martha
that that that was good
number 28 day of the moon really
cathartic way to beat the silence i
and the whole thing it's creepy it's
tens filled i love it
number 141 the time of the doctor it's
trying to cram too much into one story
and the vibe does not match a
regeneration story at all it just
doesn't
number 27 the pandorica opens this is
brilliant build
up and some stellar moments i wish the
payoff
worked but you know what this still does
number 142
knock knock kind of a dull setup kind of
dull characters
kind of a dull story number 26 face the
raven this would have been the perfect
send-off for clara
everything the consequences of her
actions they come home to roost so to
speak
and it's powerful number 143 the zygon
invasion
this one doesn't have the amazing speech
to save it
number 25 oxygen intense dramatic
atmospheric and i love the theming
number 144 closing time whatever it was
that worked about the doctrine craig
before is not working anymore number 24
the doctor falls
had this been the actual regeneration
story this thing would be near the top
it's still really good number 145 the
rings of acaten i think it's pretty
telling that i can't even tell you what
goes on in the speech about memory
number 23 the girl who waited wonderful
performances
in this one and really good emotional
heart too number 146 the witch finders
it ain't interesting and they basically
just have king james recite his own
wikipedia page
number 22 journey's end a little
self-indulgent maybe but boy
it felt like it earned it number 147 the
timeless children
my issue with this is much less about
canon messing with and just
why why why what what's the point
what are we doing number 21 world enough
and
time killer opening the death of a
companion and then
the creeptastic way of
doing the cybermen yes number 148 the
doctor's daughter maybe is a two-parter
with some room to breathe it could have
worked but i have no investment in jenny
and the conflict is stupid
number 20 amy's choice i like reality
bending and i love the dream lord
number 149 evolution of the daleks
whatever potential there was in daleks
take manhattan is
pissed away here number 19 doomsday
rip roaring good time until it kicks you
in the gut
number 150 father's day super obvious
solution for how this thing's going to
be resolved and some of the most
pointless needless monsters in the
history of doctor who
i still don't think it works i'm sorry
number eighteen can you hear me theming
is everything on this one and
i think it nails it number 151 the
battle of rand's core avcolos
there isn't even really a battle that
should tell you everything
number 17 a good man goes to war way to
raise the doctor up and then bring him
down and then
inject the hope right back into it oh
yeah
number 152 new earth really lazy alien
design
bringing back a villain that had no
business coming back and just
nothing really to recommend this number
16 the doctor's wife
such a fun concept and a brilliant bunch
of performances
number 153 the long game i like simon
pegg in it but he can't save this
number 15 the 11th hour that is a
stellar way to kick off not only a new
series but a new doctor's era
number 154 kill the moon fails on
logistical level fails on thematic level
that's a double failure let's move on
number 14 the impossible planet the
tension in this one
is so well built up and the music's
incredible number 155 journey to the
center of the tardis
brilliant title and even a neat idea but
just a
nothing of an episode number 13 human
nature who could have thought that
making the doctor not even the doctor
anymore could be so compelling number
156 and the force of the night it's bad
in ways that are weird enough that you
kind of tilt your head at it but that's
about all the novelty you'll get
you just get to see it a little bit
tilted number 12
family of blood such good resolution to
what had been built up and
such a strong ending chilling
number 157 the wedding of river song
this is just too much going on and it's
it's a garbled mess
this is a disaster of a finale number 11
dalek how do you reintroduce such iconic
villains
you take one and only one and show
everybody
why they should be scared number 158
nightmare and silver
there's like maybe one good idea with
the idea of the cyber controller trying
to take over the doctor's brain but that
isn't even particularly well
executed so then there's just nothing
but annoyance
number 10 blink dr light done right
the weeping angels introduced so
good number 159 loving monsters i get
what it was going for and what it was
going
for was an interesting notion but none
of the execution works
number nine mummy on the orient express
my platonic ideal of a completely
self-contained doctor who story
i love almost everything about this
number 160 the saranga conundrum
alien is not intimidating situation
isn't interesting supporting characters
aren't interesting
i got nothing number eight vincent and
the doctor
such a good look at depression not only
those who suffer it
but those who care about people who
suffer it it's
touching brilliant wonderful number 161
orphan55 i appreciate the message it was
going for but it hammers it really badly
and the structure doesn't work and the
supporting cast is junk
number seven silence in the library be
afraid of the dark
introduce river song the library is
frankly a brilliant setting
oh everything i like number 162
hellbent look the performers gave their
all trying to make this thing work but
it's
just a mess it just is number six the
night of the doctor yes i'm counting
this as a short
no i'm not counting any other shorts
this is the only one that deserves to be
here
it is seven minutes of perfection
number 163 arachnids in the uk giant
spiders is the kind of idea the writer
scribbles out on a notepad when he's
trying to leave his desk and go to lunch
and then you add a
really terrible political satire
character on top of that
number five the empty child
that thing scared the ever living crap
out of me
this introduces jack harkness
it's just great and creepy and
funny in just the right ways so good
number 164 the lazarus experiment the
idea is kind of stupid and the effects
oh god they really overreached the
structure's strange too
number four forest of the dead what
happens
to river and donna is heartbreaking
what happens at the end is triumphant
and
touching this is the perfect emotional
roller coaster
number 165 sleep no more absolutely
pointless gimmick bolted onto a story
that is not only uninteresting but
suffers from one of the stupidest
monster concepts in the history of the
show
number three midnight the doctor on his
own
when the one thing that is always what
he can count on his ability to keep
talking
is the very thing that is going to make
him lose
166 fear her this is probably the
episode with the least
good in it i'm not sure there's anything
that actually works in this
number two heaven sent
the doctor completely on his own my
favorite doctor
being put through the ringer in a way
that twisted my heart and made it sink
and then
soar at the end this is
brilliant and down at the bottom number
167
the idiot's lantern i may have said that
fear her had the least good in it
that may be true but this is one of the
only episodes that i find
actually personally deeply
painfully offensive
and if you don't know why there's the
review
screw this episode and number one
the doctor dances
wonderful amazing tension built up how
could they possibly win and not only do
they win
but everybody lives i don't care if that
sentiment
got deluded by overuse later on it
is perfectly deployed here and maybe the
single crowning achievement
of the entire revive series of doctor
who
everybody lives and i love this episode
so much and that is my ranking
from the bottom to the top all 167 of
what i wanted to consider
things given that i snuck one in there
with nine of the doctor
as i said i am not standing by this list
in future but today this is what you get
what are your thoughts on it thank you
again so much for 50 000 subscribers the
fact that this is my job is incredible
but that growth means the world to me
whatever your thoughts are on this drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it you can support me on
patreon there's a link down in the
description
and that is what enables me to do this
for a living there's also youtube
memberships now if you want to support
me that way as well there's perks
either way it is greatly appreciated if
you are not in a position to be able to
do that or
simply don't want to well you know what
like share subscribe
those help me out and combat the dreaded
algorithm
but i'm not going to hammer on you too
hard for that either
because my friends
over 50 000 of you
you are the council
just running the meetings and until next
time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]